und wir widmen uns dem nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt an diesem Freitag top
31 pardon top 31 in dieser
in dieser Sitzungswoche der
gesammeltitel des Maßnahmenpaket zu
Bekämpfung von Energiekrise und
Inflation und wenn sich ein bisschen bei
uns gewesen sind heute im Laufe des
Vormittags dann wird Ihnen auffallen
hoppla das Thema hatten wir doch gerade
erst aber jetzt haben wir es halt noch
mal diesmal mit zur Anträgen aus der
afd-fraktion in einem fordert die AFD
ein Maßnahmenpaket gegen die Inflation
und dabei helfen soll unter anderem
steht hier tatsächlich in diesem Antrag
eine Aufhebung des Gas Embargos gegen
Russland damit insbesondere wieder mehr
Gas nach Deutschland fließt und durch
ein Angebot ein Ende der
Angebotsknappheit die hohen
Energiepreise gesenkt werden ich hatte
das anders abgespeichert die aktuelle
Lage aber seistraum Jürgen Pohl ist der
erste Redner in dieser Debatte und er
ist bereits am Pult
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
verehrte Kollegen Werte Zuschauer Heim
an den Geräten wir erleben in diesen
Tagen eine dramatische Zuspitzung der
sozialen und wirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung hin zu einer massiven
Wirtschaftskrise wir wissen alle die
Inflation hat aktuell den höchsten Wert
seit fast 50 Jahren erreicht so lag die
Inflationsrate im August 22 trotz
Tankrabatt trotz 9 euro-ticket bei 7,9
Prozent speziell Verbraucherpreise für
Energie stiegen laut Angaben des
Statistischen Bundesamtes um ganze 35,6
Prozent und dabei war der Preistreiber
wohl der Gaspreis
die Preise für den Liter Benzin oder
Diesel und für die nicht anwesenden
Kanzler zur Information haben inzwischen
wieder die zwei Euro-Marke durchbrochen
was insbesondere die Menschen im
ländlichen Raum wie in meinen Wahlkreis
in Nordthüringen in die Existenznot
treibt die rasante Teuerung hat
verschiedene Ursachen so etwa die
verfehlte Geldpolitik der AZ die EZB die
wir als Alternative für Deutschland von
Anfang an kritisiert haben aber auch die
Folgen einer völlig verkorkten
corona-politik mit Störung der
Lieferketten und schließlich der von der
Bundesregierung angezettelte
Wirtschaftskrieg gegen die Russische
Föderation
dieser Wirtschaftskrieg kommt angesichts
der strukturellen Abhängigkeit
Deutschlands von russischen Energien
quasi einem volkswirtschaftlichen
selbstmordgleich
hinzu kommt dass die Teuerung von der
Politik weiterhin vorsätzlich gewollt
und gesteuert ist der Bürger soll durch
künstliche Preissteigerung zu einem
bestimmten Verhalten erzogen werden
damit politisch definierte Ziele wie zum
Beispiel die globale Klimarettung und
die schon heute
wirtschaftsfeindliche Energiewende
erreicht werden diese grüne Inflation
die bereits bestehende Inflation und
trifft in und betrifft in erster Linie
die Haushalte im unteren
Einkommensbereich die ich hier vertrete
sie betrifft die Ärmsten der
Gesellschaft vor allem die Rentner
Behinderten und alleinerziehend und
jetzt lachen sie weiter über die
Probleme die die Menschen da draußen
haben
umso mehr muss daher die Beseitigung
hausgemachter inflationsursachen
nachgedacht werden etwa die horrende
Besteuerung von Energie und die
CO2-Abgabe im Fokus es kann nicht sein
dass der Bürger täglich einen
Kaufkraftverlust der leidet während der
Bund und die Länder hochrändesteuer
Mehreinnahmen verbuchen der Staat darf
nicht auf Kosten der Bürger zu Profiteur
der Krise werden
wir fordern daher alle notwendigen
Maßnahmen zu ergreifen die das Angebot
an energieausweiten gemeint ist hier die
Breite Erschließung einheimischer
Quellen von Kohle und Gas sowie der
Weiterbetrieb der Kernkraftwerke zudem
sind alle embargo-maßnahmen gegen
Russland umgehend zu beenden damit mehr
Öl und Gas nach Deutschland fließt und
schließlich unendlich nehmen sie endlich
Nordstemmen 2 im Betrieb unser Land
zuerst das ist das Gebot der Stunde
[Applaus]
apropos embargo-maßnahmen nicht nur die
Bundesregierung versagt in der aktuellen
Krise kläglich auch die handzahme
Opposition und der März da ist gewaltig
der hohen drin so ist der Sündenfall der
CDU nicht etwa die kürzlich beschlossene
Frauenquote die ist nicht weg unwichtig
für unser Land nein es war der Ruf des
Achs zu wirtschaftskundigen
CDU-Vorsitzenden Friedrich Merz im März
diesen Jahres nach einem Embargo gegen
russische Gaslieferung was für eine
fatale fehlereinschätzung in Anbetracht
der heutigen Debatte schlimmer kann man
die die Industrialisierung Deutschlands
nicht vorantreiben
daher die Frage an die orientierungslose
CDU wessen Interessen vertreten sie
die Strategen die Strategen
der mit ihrem überteuerten
Versorgungsangeboten sind offenbar ihre
Stichwortgeber nicht das Grundgesetz mit
seinen klaren Vorgaben zum Schutz des
eigenen Volkes vor Armut und sozialer
Not
aber Werte Bundesregierung das Volk
braucht Entlastung das beste
Entlastungspaket was sie dem deutschen
Volk geben können ist die Rücktritt das
Volk hat es verdient dankeschön
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Pohl
[Applaus]
das nächste ist das Wort die Kollegen
Annika Klose SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
ich muss sagen heute fällt es mir schwer
diese Rede hier zu halten denn wir haben
heute einen unfassbar tollen Kollegen
verloren aus unseren Reihen und ich
finde an Tagen wie diesen denkt man dann
immer noch mal mehr darüber nach wofür
man eigentlich seine Lebensenergie so
aufbringt und ich finde es halt
irgendwie frustrierend mit solchen
schwurbel-anträgen wie der hier vorliegt
eben meine Lebensenergie verschwenden zu
müssen und vor allem halt eben auch nein
ich werde nicht aufhören zu reden weil
sie hier ihre verlogenen Thesen
verbreiten sie erzählen nämlich zum
Beispiel von einem von der
Bundesrepublik
Wirtschaftskrieg ich meine wie verquer
kann man eigentlich unterwegs sein
[Applaus]
der griffen hat
weil es einfach nicht in Ordnung ist und
gegen das Völkerrecht verstößt einfach
ein anderes Land zu überfallen auch wenn
Sie das vielleicht in ihrer Welt für in
Ordnung halten tut dir die
Weltgemeinschaft das nicht und wir schon
gar nicht jetzt möchte ich einen Blick
werfen auf diesen Antrag den Sie hier
vorgelegt haben zudem sie auch mit
keinem einzigen Wort gesprochen haben
aber es ist eigentlich finde ich schon
ehrlich gesagt eine intellektuelle
Beleidigung was sie hier liefern sie
schreiben Bürgern helfen statt
Luftschlösser bauen Maßnahmenpaket zu
Bekämpfung von in der Krise die Krise
und Inflation und man liest tatsächlich
keinen einzigen sinnvollen Vorschlag sie
schreiben erster Punkt die Europäische
Zentralbank soll anhand ihrer Ziele dass
Mandat ausüben ja das tut sie doch
zweitens die embargo Maßnahmen gegen
Russland zu beenden damit wir mehr Gas
nach Deutschland
gegen Russland das haben sie sich
ausgedacht das stimmt nicht und gucken
Sie mal Leute Typ 1 ist ja sogar in
am Ende kein Gast kannst du dich damit
mal auseinandergesetzt die verbreiten
hier einfach Unfug Entschuldigung und
drittens ist ihr Punkten wir sollen alle
Angebote nutzen um Energie aus an
energieausweiten ja das tun wir doch
erneuerbare Energien hat noch keine
Bundesregierung so vorangetrieben wie
diese sie ihr wollt aber Erdgas und
Kohle und dann sagen sie damit würde man
eben die Bürger schützen haben Sie schon
mal was vom Klimawandel gehört und den
Folgen und den Kosten die damit
einhergehen und wer trägt das am Ende
das sind diejenigen die am wenigsten
haben in dieser Gesellschaft und auf
diesen Globus und solidarische Maßnahmen
ohne Ende am schärfsten finde ich aber
tatsächlich ihren Punkt 5c den Sie in
diesem Antrag hier jetzt auftischen da
schreiben sie nämlich ich zitiere der
Regelbedarf für die Grundsicherung für
Arbeitssuchende und so weiter
pauschal und Existenz sichern zu erhöhen
ja da Chor natürlich muss das erhöht
werden denn die Menschen kommen ja nicht
über die Runden und deswegen werden wir
auch zum ersten ersten mit der
Einführung des bürgergel den Regelsatz
um 50 Euro anheben auf 502 Euro pro
Monat und das ist richtig so sie fordern
das und dann und dann sagen sie aber
gleichzeitig in einer Pressemitteilung
ihres fraktionsfeeds des Bürgergeld
nehme der Arbeit eine Bevölkerung jeden
Leistungswillen Bürgergeld nach
ampelplänen bedeute viele die heute hart
arbeiten dass sie dann weniger hätten
das heißt einerseits fordern sie
Sicherungsmaßnahmen so wie wir und
andererseits fangen sie dann an Leute
Niedriglohnsektor dagegen auszuspielen
und zwar kennen dass wir genau diese
Gruppen noch unterstützen mit all den
Paketen und nachher die wir Ihnen diese
ganze Woche vorgelegt haben also da muss
ich mich wirklich fragen wie es
eigentlich sein fantasieren die 30 Grad
haben sich hier hinzustellen und zu
erzählen sie würden genau diese Leute
vertreten Entschuldigung mitnichten
davon kann man nun wirklich nicht
sprechen was sie machen ist hier Hetze
zu verbreiten und eben überhaupt keinen
einzigen konstruktiven Vorschlag
beizutragen sie kommt ihrer
Verantwortung für dieses Land nicht nach
diese Bundesregierung schon und das
genug gesagt vielen Dank
Annika Klose zu den Anträgen der
afd-fraktion und ganz am Anfang hat sie
auch noch mal Bezug genommen auf den Tod
des SPD-Abgeordneten Rainer Keller der
gestern überraschend gestorben ist im
Alter von 56 Jahren und für den die
Fraktion ein Platz heute hier
freigehalten hat samt Blumengesteck um
an ihn zu erinnern der Bundestag
diskutiert derweil weiter über die
afd-anträge am Pult ist Maximilian
mörseburg aus der Unionsfraktion zur
Bekämpfung von Inflation und
Energiekrise
ihr Abgeordneter weil wünscht dem
gesamten Land derweil einen dramatischen
Winter
und dass die Energiekrise Deutschland
hart treffe weil er sich davon ein paar
Prozent mehr für die AFD erhofft
diesmal waren die Migros noch an ich
glaube das ist bei ihnen aber der
Äußerung die häufiger fällt und das
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren ist
im gegen dem was hier sonst behaupten
das Gegenteil von Patriotismus und das
erklärt diesen handwerklichen inhaltlich
schwachen Antrag genauso wie es die
Äußerung von Herrn Pohl gerade hier im
Rednerpult und auch die Erklärung in
ihrem Antrag für die ausbleibenden
Gaslieferung mit einem Embargo und eben
nicht mit dem Angriffskrieg Russlands
gegen die Ukraine und putins-
aber auch sonst kann man ja mit den
meisten ihrer Vorschläge nicht viel
anfangen als Beispiel habe ich mich
schon gewundert dass Frau Dr Weidel als
Volkswirtin einen Antrag unterschreibt
in dem zur Bekämpfung der Inflation
Maßnahmen genannt werden sollen und
nachher im Mindestlohn die aktuelle
Preisentwicklung mitberücksichtigt
werden soll also die aktuelle
Preisentwicklung mit im Mindestlohn
berücksichtigen wenn die Löhne steigen
weil die Preise gestiegen sind dann
steigen doch die Preise wiederum weil
die Löhne gestiegen sind das ist
volkswirtschaftlicher Quatsch was Sie da
schreiben in dem an dem Antrag aber sie
hören da nicht auf meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren sie schreiben dass sie
richtige Preisentwicklung
berücksichtigen wollen im Mindestlohn
zukünftige haben sie dann an die eigene
angetriebene Inflation in ihrer
Berechnung des Mindestlohns als auch
schon mit drin meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren die lohnt Preisspirale
bedankt sich sehr herzlich bei den
ahnungslosen Erfüllungsgehilfen hier im
Parlament
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
tatsache ist jedoch dass dieser Winter
einer der schwierigsten werden könnte
den jedenfalls die meisten von uns
erlebt haben als Unionsfraktion sind wir
der Meinung dass wir den Menschen die
Angst nehmen müssen unser
Wirtschaftsminister stellt sich leider
aber hin und nimmt den Bürger nicht die
Angst sondern sagt wir könnten es
vielleicht schaffen durch den Winter
vielleicht haben wir eine Chance mit dem
richtigen Wetter das klingt für mich
nicht nach Angst nehmen aber es dient
vor allem für mich nicht danach als
könnten wir zurzeit drei Kernkraftwerke
entbehren insbesondere in
Baden-Württemberg wo ich herkommt wo 15
Prozent des Strombedarfs durch keine
Energie gedeckt wird und wo man bis zu
der Hälfte der Haushalte mit Kernenergie
versorgen kann meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren
zudem möchte die Bundesregierung an der
umstrittenen gasumlage festhalten die
bereits obsolet ist und rechtlich auch
fragwürdig sie wollen den Leuten also
Geld wegnehmen statt sie zu entlasten
gleichzeitig aber mit der Gießkanne die
ganze Zeit inflationstreibende Maßnahmen
die abwechselnd über verschiedene Teilen
der Bevölkerung ausgebreitet werden
klüger wäre gewesen statt den 300 Euro
jeweils 1000 Euro für diejenigen die es
wirklich nötig haben anstatt 300 Euro
für alle auch für Sie und für mich nun
planen Sie mit der nächsten Maßnahme
3000 Euro steuerfreie Zahlungen
zugegebenermaßen in Sachen Inflation ist
die Einmalzahlung persönlich die
schlechteste Variante aber wenn wir
Inflation bekämpfen möchten und
gleichzeitig sozial entlasten Liebe
Bundesregierung dann müssen wir uns
darauf einigen dass wir eben nur
diejenigen unterstützen die es wirklich
nötig haben und diejenigen in Ruhe
lassen die den Laden am Laufen halten
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
natürlich freue ich mich für die Leute
gerade in meinem Wahlkreis in Stuttgart
bei den großen Unternehmen die von
diesen 3000 Euro steuerfrei ganz
bestimmt profitieren werden ich freue
mich für sie aber ist es dann
zielgerichtete Hilfe und was sagen sie
den Bäckermeister den ich letzte Woche
besucht habe der diese 3000 Euro seinen
Leuten gar nicht auszahlen kann was
sagen sie den Bäckermeister der das
nicht bekommen wird wenn sein Nachbar
der beim daimlerschaft eben die 3000
Euro nachher bekommen hat was sagen Sie
diesen Leuten und was machen sie wenn
aus ihrer
Unterstützungsleistung eine Umverteilung
von unten nach oben wird am Ende meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren alles in
allem wirken diese Maßnahmen der
Bundesregierung leider unkoordiniert
nicht vom Ende
und wie so vieles in ihrer Koalition
versuchen sie eben alle glücklich zu
machen ich verstehe das aber es
funktioniert nicht am Ende macht man
damit eben nicht alle glücklich sondern
kann keinem so richtig helfen wenn sie
sich jedoch auf die Grundlagen der
sozialen Marktwirtschaft besinnen indem
sie den schwächsten helfen und die
anderen in Ruhe lassen dann können wir
diese gut diese Krise gut meistern wir
unterstützen Sie gerne dabei vielen Dank
vielen Dank Maximilian mörseburg und
seine Sicht auf die Anträge der AFD die
hier diskutiert werden in denen ein
Maßnahmenpaket gegen die Inflation
gefordert wird und außerdem ein
Schutzschirm für Menschen mit
Behinderung sowie für soziale
Einrichtung Felix bannaschak jetzt zu
diesem Thema
Dialektik und Schizophrenie ist schmal
und ich glaube sie sind ein bisschen
ausgerutscht gerade es ist sie haben
hier den ganzen die ganze Woche damit
verbracht sie haben die ganze Woche
damit verbracht von dieser
Bundesregierung zu erwarten überall zu
helfen überall Geld reinzugeben kein
Wort zu geben finanzieren zu sagen jetzt
über zielgerichtete Hilfe zu sprechen
gerade die schwächsten anzusprechen
gleichzeitig gegen das Bürgergeld zu
polymisieren das funktioniert in einer
Rede auf jeden Fall nicht ohne den Sinn
und Verstand zu verlieren
meine Damen und Herren wenn man die
Probleme lösen will von denen wir stehen
muss man sie erst mal
verstehen und deswegen hilft der AFD da
gerne nach warum haben wir die Inflation
die Inflation ist deswegen da weil wir
gestiegene Energiepreise haben die
wirken sich dann wiederum auf
energieintensive Industrien und das
Handwerk auf das wird dann sicher
beispielsweise bei den Lebensmitteln auf
warum sind die Energiepreise gestiegen
weil wir auf der einen Seite einen
Mangel haben verursacht durch den
Kriegsverbrecher bleiben mir Putin und
zum anderen Spekulation der auf diesem
Mangel aufbaut das bedeutet die Ursache
der Inflation über die wir sprechen ist
der Wirtschaftskrieg den Wladimir Putin
mit Hilfe von Energie und ist der
brutale Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
den er vom Zaun gebrochen hat und da sie
sich gerade wieder als Sachverwalter der
Russischen Föderation hier im Deutschen
Bundestag gerührt haben sie sagen in
ihrem Antrag des Gärtner grüne Inflation
wenn diese Inflation irgendeine Farbe
hat dann ist es so braun wie ihr
Gedankengut
und wenn wir jetzt über die Bekämpfung
der Inflation sprechen wenn wir jetzt
über die Bekämpfung der Inflation
sprechen dann glaube ich müssen wir
einen Fehler bringen vermeiden wir haben
eine Nachfrage wir haben einen
angebotsschock den ich gerade
beschrieben habe aber diese Angebot
Schock hat jetzt schon eine Wirkung dass
wir merken Menschen gehen in ihrem
Konsumverhalten zurück sie fragen sich
will ich jetzt gerade renovieren meine
Wohnung will ich jetzt gerade ein Auto
kaufen will ich jetzt gerade
irgendwelche Konsumgüter kaufen wenn
doch ich nicht genau weiß wie ich am
Ende meines Strom und Gasrechnung
bezahlen soll und deswegen müssen wir in
zweierlei Hinsicht darauf reagieren
erstens wir müssen auf der Angebotsseite
nachsteuern das tun wir intensiv und das
werden wir in den nächsten Wochen und
Monaten weiter tun mit einer Ausweitung
der energiekapazitäten deswegen unter
anderem schnellere Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren und sämtlicher Deckel dafür
Weg zweitens werden wir aber auch darauf
reagieren indem wir insgesamt
insbesondere die unterstützen die unter
diesen angestiegenen Preisen besonders
leiden sich jetzt in eine noch tiefere
Rezession hinein zu sparen als sie sich
eh schon bedeutet das wäre ökonomisch
tatsächlich irrsinnig und deswegen wird
diese Bundesregierung auch Mario Draghi
hat an anderer Stelle einmal richtig
gesagt whatever it takes whatever it
takes das wird diese Bundesregierung tun
Unternehmen zu stabilisieren
Gesellschaft zu stabilisieren die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu stabilisieren
in diesen schweren Zeiten damit sie
ihren Job noch ein bisschen schwerer
machen können als eh schon vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Felix banaschak
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen ihm wird
jetzt Folgen aus der Linksfraktion
Susanne ferschel und da ist sie
Sprecherin für Arbeit und Mitbestimmung
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen bei
Energie und Lebensmittel explodieren die
Preise die Inflation ist so hoch wie
seit 50 Jahren nicht mehr und für
Beschäftigte bedeutet das dass sie jeden
Tag ärmer werden auch wenn sie täglich
zur Arbeit gehen aufs Jahr berechnet
verlieren Sie ein komplettes
Monatseinkommen das ist doch Wahnsinn
und der Finanzminister hat versprochen
in ich zitiere in diesem Land wird im
Winter niemand hungern und niemand
frieren mal ganz abgesehen davon dass
diese Äußerung alleine schon eine
politische bankroterklärung ist frage
ich mich in welchem Paralleluniversum
lebt eigentlich Christian Lindner die
Tafeln sind so überfüllt dass sie die
Menschen abweisen müssen Strom und
Gaskunden rufen verzweifelt bei ihren
Energieversorgern an und ich zitiere aus
dem Handelsblatt sie schreien sie weinen
einige Drohnen sogar mit Selbstmord weil
sie jetzt schon nicht mehr wissen wie
sie ihre Rechnungen bezahlen sollen
statt Lehren Versprechungen muss diese
Bundesregierung endlich handeln
wir brauchen für Privatkunden aber auch
für kleine und mittelständische Betriebe
endlich einen wirksamen preisdeckel für
Gas und Strom halb Europa hat seit
Monaten einen solchen preisdeckel und
die übergewende werden dort besteuert um
sie Bevölkerung zu unterstützen bei uns
läuft es umgekehrt der zieht die
Bundesregierung den Leuten durch die
gasumlage noch zusätzlich das Geld aus
der Tasche während Energie und auch
Lebensmittelkonzerne den Reibach ihres
Lebens machen was für eine absurde
Politik
genauso wie das die Fasel über eine
drohende
lohnpreisspirale das schlägt ein
wohlgemerkt sozialdemokratischer Kanzler
steuerfrei Einmalzahlungen vor die noch
dazu freiwillig sind ja wo bleibt denn
das Tariftreuegesetz und die
Erleichterung von
allgemeinverbindlicherklärungen die
Beschäftigten brauchen nämlich deutliche
dauerhafte Tarifsteigerungen keine
einmaligen Notgroschen
merkt die Bundesregierung merkt die
Bundesregierung eigentlich dass hier
eine gefährliche Mischung aus
Verzweiflung auf der einen und tiefer
Frust über die soziale Ungerechtigkeit
auf der anderen Seite entsteht und diese
Interessen und diese interessengeleitete
und ungerechte Politik sie hilft dem
Trupp hier Rechtsaußen die wollen
nämlich nach eigenen Aussagen das ist
Deutschland schlecht geht und sie
wünschen sich einen dramatischen Winter
und sie von der AFD sie fordern in ihrem
Antrag einen Inflationsausgleich zum
Mindestlohn einem Gesetz den sie hier
nicht mal zugestimmt haben sie fordern
eine Erhöhung der Regelsätze obwohl er
reden heute Morgen des Bürgergeld noch
diffamiert hat und gesagt hat es würde
alle bestrafen die fleißig arbeiten ihre
Scheinheiligkeit und doppeltsündigkeit
ist wirklich durch nichts zu überbieten
und deshalb an die Bundesregierung als
Appell behalten Sie bitte Ihre
Energiespartipps für sich hören sie auf
auf gutes Wetter im Winter zu hoffen
machen ein und machen eine Politik im
Sinne der Mehrheit der Bevölkerung in
diesem Land und die nicht weiter zu
stärken vielen Dank
Susanne Fercher für die Linksfraktion
und es geht hier nach wie vor um zwei
Anträge aus der afd-fraktion ich sage
Redner dazu wird sein Jens teutrine aus
der FDP-Fraktion oder ist Sprecher für
Bürgergeld unter anderem liebe Kollegen
und Kollegen und meistens ist es gar
nicht so interessant was Politiker sagen
viel häufiger ist es interessant worüber
Politiker auch mal schweigern wo sie sie
wozu sie nichts sagen und der afd-rät
nach hat nicht zu den russischen
eingriffskrieg gesagt er hat nichts über
die Kriegsverbrechen gesagt und die
foltern an Soldaten und Soldaten er hat
nichts über die Vergewaltigungen gesagt
er hat nichts über die Verschleppungen
von Kindern gesagt sondern stattdessen
unterstellt er dieser Bundesregierung
ein Wirtschaftskrieg zu führen in
Wahrheit müssen sie den Täter bei Namen
nennen Wladimir Putin führt ein
russischen Angriffskrieg und das haben
sie verschwiegen das verschweigen sie
immer wieder ganz bewusst
und und es gibt ja das wird jetzt einige
überraschen und vielleicht auch einige
Zuschauer es gibt etwas was viele
Abgeordneten in diesem Haus gemeinsam
haben und sogar Abgeordnete der AFD
nämlich werden Sie in diesem Wochenende
wieder in ihre Wahlkreise fahren sie
werden wieder mit den Menschen sprechen
nur dass die meisten Abgeordneten der
demokratischen Parteien in ihren
Wahlkreisen nach Deutschland fahren und
ihre Abgeordneten fahren lieber nach
Russland die die vier
Landtagsabgeordneten und Frau Walde sagt
dann sie würde sie würden eine
privatreiseunternehmen man wusste von
alles nichts andere afd-abgeordnete
sagen wir wussten davon dass die in die
Kriegsgebiete reisen wollen und das ist
von den Landtag in Sachsen-Anhalt
finanziert wird sie machen Wahlkreis
Arbeit in Russland und tun so als wenn
sie die Interessen dieser Menschen in
Deutschland
vertreten wenn sie sagen
Deutschlands Interessen zuerst meinen
Sie putinsinteressen zuerst eine
Zwischenfrage keine zwischen
und deswegen
für den Zwischenruf Lügner in
Ordnungsruf und ich warne sie noch mal
die nächste Maßnahme von mir bedeutet
jetzt an das muss ich ja tun weil diese
ständigen Zwischenrufe ihrerseits den
Martin Ablauf massiv stören dort
trainiert
aber es ist richtig dass die
Bundesregierung weiter über Entlastungen
bringt es sind schon einige auf dem Weg
gebracht worden allein in dieser Woche
haben wir das inflationsausgleichsgesetz
beispielsweise eingebracht und die
Mehrbelastungen für die Mitte der
Gesellschaft auch abzufedern für
diejenigen die arbeiten gehen die Grünen
haben in der Debatte ganz offen
transparent gemacht bei den Kollegen
outritt dass sie das dieses Vorhaben
nicht unterstützt hätten das ist ein
Kompromiss ist gegen andere Entlastungen
umso wichtiger ist es dass es den
Bundesfinanzminister Christian Lindner
gibt damit sich jemand auch für
Entlastung der Mitte der Gesellschaft
stark macht weil die haben es auch
verdient und sie sind ebenfalls von der
Inflation betroffen
und es wurde ja viel auch über das
Bürgergeld in den letzten Tagen
gesprochen über den Inflationsausgleich
für Menschen in der Grundsicherung in
Hartz-IV-System werden 20 Euro mehr
gewesen beim Bürgergeld sind es jetzt 50
Euro pro Monat mehr und die Kollegin der
CDU hat eben schon dazwischen gerufen
welche Katastrophe es ist dass man jetzt
das Bürgergeld erhöhen und ich finde die
Union hat eine wichtige staatspolitische
Verantwortung die wichtige
staatspolitische Verantwortung der Union
ist es die Regierung zu treiben es ist
wichtig dass Sie die Regierung treiben
und sie kritisieren und das nicht den
Rändern überlassen es ist wichtig dass
die eigene Vorschläge machen von denen
wir sogar einige unterstützen
beispielsweise beim Weiterbetrieb der
Kernkraftwerke aber es gehört auch zu
einer konstruktiven Oppositionsarbeit
dass man nicht sechs Monate im Ausschuss
sich der darüber beschwert dass der
Regelsatz nicht erhöht wird und jetzt
sich beschwert dass der Regelsatz erhöht
wird kritisieren sie uns für
sanktionsfragen kritisieren sie uns für
Fragen nachhaltigen Integration in den
Arbeitsmarkt aber es ist unehrlich ist
unehrlich wenn sie in der Öffentlichkeit
die Erhöhung des Bürgergeldes
kritisierenden wenn Sie sie selbst in
den letzten Monaten immer und immer
wieder gefordert haben dann seien sie
wenigstens zur ehrlich und sagen heute
dass sie gegen eine Erhöhung sind für
Menschen im Existenzminimum
also ist es richtig Menschen zu
unterstützen die von Sozialleistungen
abhängig sind es ist richtig aber auch
die Mitte der Gesellschaft in den Blick
zu nehmen gleichzeitig ist aber genauso
richtig auch bei den Ursachen von
Inflationen anzusetzen nämlich Angebot
zu erweitern als Fraktion stehen wir
deswegen auch weiterhin dazu dass es
richtig ist die Kernkraft weiter die
Kernkraftwerke die klimaneutral sind
auch weiter zu betreiben es ist eine
Frage der Vernunft wir müssen im
Reservebetrieb ebenfalls investiert
investieren es kostet uns ebenfalls Geld
dass wir sie im
reservierbetrieb halten aber es ist
notwendig dass wir auch eine dämpfende
Wirkung bei den aktuell steigenden
Strompreisen haben deswegen der
Dreiklang ja Menschen in der
Existenzsicherung absichern aber die
Inflation reicht bis in die Mitte der
Gesellschaft und die Menschen müssen
ebenfalls entlastet werden und auch
Unternehmen und Selbstständige müssen
entlastet werden aber wir müssen auch
neben lng-terminals nehmen die Anwendung
von biogasmasse auch über den
Weiterbetrieb von nur klimaneutralen
Kernkraftwerken diskutieren wir werden
uns da stark machen wir freuen uns auf
eine Opposition die da auch der auch die
Regierung treibt und ich freue mich auf
die weitere Debatte im Ausschuss
für die SPD-Fraktion hat nun der Kollege
takimi mit Ali das Wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren erlauben Sie
mir vielleicht noch eine Bemerkung bevor
ich in den Antrag eingehe
in der letzten Debatte kein Wort über
Kinder mit Behinderung zu verlieren erst
recht nicht über Mädchen mit Behinderung
zu verlieren das empfinde ich als
know-gau das empfinde ich als ziemlich
mies ich glaube das kriegen wir
demnächst mal in diesem Haus noch besser
hin
hier zu dem Antrag ich bleibe bei
Menschen mit Behinderung ich erkläre
Ihnen gerne warum der Antrag der AFD
fachlich und sachlich nicht korrekt ist
und auch
im Rahmen dessen überhaupt nicht mit dem
einhergeht was für ein Rechtsverständnis
wir haben grundsätzlich ist erstmal für
die Eingliederungshilfe die Länder
zuständig das haben wir 2016 ganz klar
geregelt die Länder haben dafür gekämpft
dass sie weiterhin für die
Eingliederungshilfe zuständig sind und
wir unterstützen sogar die Länder darin
indem wir innerhalb des
bthg-umsetzungsprozesses 5 Milliarden
Euro dazugeben und das wird auch so
umgesetzt und vor allen Dingen ist auch
nach §94 sgb-9 die Länder eindeutig
dafür zuständig und auch für den
Sicherstellungsauftrag sind die Länder
zuständig und die AFD zeigt hiermit auch
letztendlich dass sie nicht verstanden
haben was sie beantragt
so was passiert denn aber in den
Kommunen momentan die Länder müssen
jetzt auch in dieser Krise mehr
Verantwortung übernehmen momentan
meistern wir ganz viel aus seitens des
Bundes und jetzt sind die Länder
gefordert auch mal Flagge zu Seiten im
Rahmen der Eingliederungshilfe dass sie
die überhöhten Kosten bei den
Leistungserbringern übernehmen und im
übrigen der Antrag zeigt dass sie
besonderen Wohnformen in der
Eingliederungshilfe die Kosten dort
gestiegen sind ich sage Ihnen eins wir
haben
2019/2020 die übergangsvereinbarung zur
Umsetzung des bundesteilhabegesetzes in
allen Ländern eingeführt und erfolgreich
auch gemeistert für eine Budget neutrale
Umstellung gemacht das heißt auf der
einen Seite übernehmen die Einrichtung
immer noch die Stromkosten und auf der
anderen Seite übernimmt die Sozialhilfe
im sgb12 die Gaskosten das heißt was
fordern Sie hier überhaupt das haben wir
doch schon geregelt bevor sie überhaupt
auf die Idee kamen dieses Problem zu
erkennen meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren
und zusätzlich haben wir natürlich auch
seitens der SPD-Fraktion schon darauf
reagiert was haben wir gemacht ich habe
gestern ein Schreiben an alle
sozialminister:innen gesendet dass sie
die Sachkosten in der
Eingliederungshilfe bei den
Leistungserbringern anerkennen sollen
und nicht mit irgendwelchen
fake-angeboten gegenüber den
Leistungserbringern antreten sollen und
die tatsächlichen Sachkosten anerkennen
müssen und das steht so im Gesetz und
das muss auch so sein meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
aber in diesem Zusammenhang muss man
vielleicht auch noch mal erwähnen dass
wir natürlich auch bei den
Vorbereitungen der Wirtschaftshilfen an
die Einrichtungen des Gesundheits- und
Sozialwesens denken werden dafür stehe
ich im Kontakt mit dem
Wirtschaftsministerium aber auch mit dem
mit dem ministeriumverarbeitung soziales
wir werden die Einrichtung des
Gesundheits- und Sozialwesens nicht
vergessen und werden diese auch bei den
Wirtschaftshilfen berücksichtigen jetzt
erzähle ich Ihnen noch aber einen ganz
peinlichen Fakt in ihrem Antrag sie
fordern tatsächlich dass die
energiepauschale auch in Zukunft an die
WfbM beschäftigen ausgezahlt werden soll
soll ich ihnen was sagen wenn sie
überhaupt die entlastungspakete gelesen
hätten dann hätten sie verstanden dass
das in diesem Monat sowieso an die WfbM
Beschäftigten ausgezahlt wird alle wf n
Beschäftigten in den EGH Einrichtungen
erhalten in diesem Monat die 300 Euro
pauschale und ich sage Ihnen noch mal
was und die haben sogar on top im Juli
die 200 Euro aus der Grundsicherung
bekommt das sind 500 Euro an die WfbM
Beschäftigten gewinnen und sie fordern
diese in diesem Antrag weil sie einfach
nicht verstehen dass komplette System
nicht verstehen das hat die Regierung
erledigt bevor Sie dieses Problem
überhaupt erkannt haben
und das wird reichen wir sind ja mit
weiteren Hilfen noch beschäftigt und
lassen Sie mich noch einen Satz
loswerden Herr Kleinwächter wenn sie
wirklich sich um die Sorgen in diesem
Land kümmern würden dann hätten sie
genug dann hätten sie nicht so viel Zeit
wie wenn sie dann in den Morgenstunden
oder Abendstunden durch die Flure durch
die SPD Flure in den einzelnen
Abgeordnetenbüros
rumschlingern und dann sich tatsächlich
vor einer vor dem Adler mit
Regenbogenfarben stehen und wirklich die
offene Gesellschaft und die Rechte der
lgbtiq Szene in diesem Land die
vermehren und sie aberkennen das ist
nicht richtig und diesem Faschismus
werden wir entgegenwirken vielen Dank
der Tag ist mir mit Ali von der SPD er
hat ja auch angesprochen die WfbM
Beschäftigten das sind die Beschäftigten
in einer Werkstatt für behinderte
Menschen
die sozialen Träger die hatten ja
durchaus auch
ihre Existenznot angekündigt und das war
ja schon häufiger jetzt Thema in dieser
Aussprache peter-ormer jetzt für die
cdu/csu-fraktion hat sowohl der Antrag
als er die Rede des Kollegen wohl
gezeigt dass es nicht der Fall ist wir
stehen meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren
in dieser Krise vor riesigen
Herausforderungen und diese Krise ist ja
nicht eine sondern sind drei Krisen
mitten in Corona in der ukraine-krise
und der Energiekrise da gibt es viel zu
tun viel auf dem Weg zu bringen damit
wir den Menschen in unserem Land helfen
eine gute Zukunft zu haben und meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren das
bedeutet wir müssen unsere Verantwortung
gerecht werden jeder an seiner Stelle
die Opposition also Oppositionen und vor
allem die Regierung die handeln muss und
nicht nur auf antreibt der Opposition
auf antriebsopposition das glaube ich
kommt auf jeden Fall zu kurz aber meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren was hier
gar nicht hilft sind die Anträge der AFD
alleine der Titel wird der
Ernsthaftigkeit der Krise nicht gerecht
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren der
AFD sie streuen den Menschen in unserem
Land Sand in die Augen sonst nichts aber
das sind wir von der AFD ja gewöhnt
das Maßnahmenpaket das Maßnahmenpaket
der AFD ist eine Ansammlung von Punkten
die nicht
lösungsorientiert sind oder Herr
Brandner rechtlich nicht umsetzbar es
ist sicherlich die nicht die Zeit der
politischen Luftschlösser da haben sie
recht aber es ist auch nicht die Zeit
des politischen wünschte was sowie dass
die AFD sieht meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren nur ein Beispiel aus dem
Antrag ist vorher schon kurz
angesprochen worden sie fordern die
Regelbedarfe für die Grundsicherung für
Arbeitssuchende pauschal und Existenz
sichern zu erhöhen ja was heißt denn das
man sollte in einer sozialpolitischen
Debatte durchaus auch wissen was man
fordert in so einer grundlegenden Frage
und wenn Sie damit nicht zurechtkommen
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
sollten Sie sich durchaus zurückhalten
aber meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und warum verfangen die Botschaften der
AFD weil die Regierung die jetzt Stärke
zeigen müsste und in ihrer Verantwortung
handeln müsste der Verantwortung nicht
gerecht wird sie haben meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren der
Ampelkoalition kein Konzept zu
Überwindung dieser Krisen in denen wir
stecken und sie hören leider und machen
leider ideologiebetriebene Politik und
nicht Politik Politik für die Menschen
dieser Welt meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren ich habe sehr früh im
Deutschen Bundestag gelernt dass Politik
mit dem Betrachten der Wirklichkeiten
beginnt beginnen sie meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren der Ampel die
Betrachtung der Wirklichkeit in unserem
Land und schauen Sie beispielsweise
nochmal ins Protokoll und hören Sie die
Debatte gestern an die Umweltministerin
hat zum Thema Atomausstieg gesagt und zu
unserem Antrag wir wollen das Rad der
der Atomkraft nicht zurückdrehen meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren wir
wollen das Rad auch nicht zurückdrehen
aber wir wollen dass die Schwere der
Krise so angepappt wird dass wir den
Menschen und den Bürgern und Bürgern
unserem Land helfen und da es bei Ihnen
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
relativ wenig zu spüren und deswegen
weniger Ideologie mehr Pragmatismus
damit helfen sie den Menschen und
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren der
Ampel dass sie kein Konzept haben merkt
man in vielen Bereichen sie haben das
dritte Entlastungspaket gemacht das
führt Entlastungspaket steht
höchstwahrscheinlich in naher Zukunft an
Menschen mit Behinderung ist vorher
angesprochen worden sind leider in den
entlastungspaketen zum Teil nicht
berücksichtigt worden die Werkstätten es
gibt klare Forderungen der Lebenshilfe
beispielsweise die Korrekturen fordern
das haben sie in ihrer Rede auch
unterschlagen dass sie kein Konzept
haben meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren zeigt aber auch die nächste
Debatte wir sprechen ja über die
Kurzarbeit wenn wir an den Ausschuss
gestern denken oder vorgestern denken es
war ja die Vorstandsvorsitzende der
Bundesagentur bei uns die Frage an sie
war wie schaut denn die Finanzierung des
Kurzarbeitergeldes an Aussage der
Vorstandsvorsitzenden war wir sind nicht
auf diese Krise vorbereitet und dass
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren der
Ampel ich habe das mitgeschrieben das
war die klare Aussage von Andrea Nahles
das meine sehr ge meine Damen und Herren
ist ein Armutszeugnis für die Ampel sie
waren selber mit dabei
ich habe sehr gut zugehört weil es meine
Frage war und ich habe aufgeschrieben
sie können keinen Protokoll nachlesen
jetzt habe ich leider nur noch zwölf
Sekunden ich kann den Rest meiner rede
jetzt nicht mehr sofort führen wie ich
das gedacht habe ich bitte Sie meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren der Ampel
werden sie ihre Verantwortung gerecht
wir unterstützen Sie dort wo Vene
Ideologie sondern die Menschen im
Mittelpunkt stehen und die Wirtschaft
und das glaube ich muss unser
gemeinsames Ziel sein herzlichen Dank
Peter Oma war das für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
[Musik]
und der nächste Redner hier kommt aus
den Rhein der Grünen Wolfgang streng man
Kuhn wird es sein er ist der Hauptmann
der Grünen im Ausschuss für Arbeit und
Soziales
der Antrag der AFD zeigt mal wieder das
Profil der AFD sie vertreten die
Interessen des Kreml sie setzen auf die
Spaltung der Gesellschaft der Kollege
mörseburg hat das schon schon erwähnt
sie setzen auf die Spaltung ihrer
Gesellschaft weil sie davon vermeintlich
profitieren das ist ihr Ziel das ist ihr
explizites Ziel aber da haben sie alle
anderen Parteien gegen sich
und das dritte ist dass sie setzen auf
die einfachen Antworten und ein kluger
Mensch hat einmal gesagt auf jedes
komplexe Problem gibt es eine einfache
Antwort und die und die ist falsch und
das ist bei ihnen auch wieder der Fall
sie setzen zum Beispiel in ihrer ersten
Forderung auf die Geldpolitik der EZB
das wäre richtig wenn wir eine Nachfrage
getriebene Inflation haben das haben wir
aber gar nicht sondern wir haben eine
preisgetriebene angebotsgetriebene
Inflation und ein nützt die Geldpolitik
der der EZB gegen Inflation gar nichts
im Gegenteil der Kollege bannata schon
gesagt wir haben Gefahren bei der
Nachfrage die droht abzusägen das heißt
es wäre jetzt eigentlich eine expansive
Fiskalpolitik notwendig um der Krise her
zu werden und die Rezession einigermaßen
in den Griffen
was stattdessen notwendig wäre statt
jetzt die Zinsen zu erhöhen eine
expansive
um Gottes Willen bloß keine
afd-regierung ist eine Partei eine
Politik die wir machen die darauf setzt
die Energieversorgung zu sichern die
darauf setzt die Preise in den Griff zu
kriegen in den letzten Paket der
Koalition haben wir vereinbart dass wir
an die Strompreise drangehen an die
Gaspreise das ist das denn ein zentraler
Punkt und wir müssen wir müssen wir
müssen umverteilend zur Zeit und wir
haben insbesondere indem wir Menschen
mit geringen und mittleren Einkommen
entlassen und das macht diese
Bundesregierung wir erhöhen den
Regelsatz in der Grundsicherung um 50
Euro die stärkste Hartz IV Erhöhung die
es überhaupt je gegeben hat
wir machen das wir erhöhen das Wohngeld
und weiten das aus damit die Menschen
die ein bisschen drüber was haben die
erhöhen das Kindergeld um Menschen in
der Mitte zu entlassen und Familien und
um das noch mal denn wir sind auch dafür
dass die kalte Progression für kleine
und mittlere Einkommen ausgeglichen wird
wo der Dissens liegt zwischen FDP und
Grünen war ob wir die kalte Progression
auch für die hohen Einkommen ausgleichen
wollen das hat der Kollege outletsch
auch gesagt in dem Gesamtpaket passte
das aber deswegen werden wir dem Gesetz
auch zustimmen aber wir sind natürlich
für die Entlastung der kleinen und
mittleren Einkommen da stehen wir auf
einer Seite und sind da gemeinsam
unterwegs
und was aber auch wichtig ist wir setzen
in dieser Krise auf Solidarität da
müssen wir dann auch noch mal gucken
dass die breiten Schultern auch mehr
tragen das ist glaube ich für den
nächsten Monate auch wichtig und wir
brauchen auch Solidarität im
Energiesparen weil wir kommen nur durch
diese Krise wenn wir alle gemeinsam auch
Energie sparen auch da ist es so dass
die Menschen mit den hohen Einkommen
dazu mehr beitragen können mehr Energie
sparen können auch wenn sie es
finanziell gar nicht unbedingt notwendig
haben sie setzen auf die Spaltung der
Gesellschaft alle anderen Sätzen aus
Solidarität und sie werden mit ihren
spaltungsversuchen nicht gewinnen
sondern die Solidarität wird gewinnen
vielen Dank ja das sagt hier
[Applaus]
in Richtung der afd-fraktion und zu
deren beiden Anträgen die hier Grundlage
dieser Aussprache sind Natalie public
für die SPD jetzt letzte Rednerin zu
diesem Tagesordnungspunkt
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
verehrte Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
wenn man mit der heißen Luft aus AFD
Anträgen heizen könnte wäre das
vermutlich da sinnvollste Beitrag den
sie liefern zu Lösung der aktuellen
Herausforderungen
was sie in ihrem Antrag als
Luftschlösser bezeichnen sind handfeste
Maßnahmen die den Menschen in unserem
Land durch diesen Winter helfen werden
das ist die strompreisbremse es ist die
Erhöhung des Kindergeldes es ist die
Verlängerung des Kurzarbeitergeldes die
Verhinderung von Strom und gassperren
die übergewinnsteuer und vieles mehr die
Einmalzahlungen für besonders betroffene
Gruppen habe ich dabei noch gar nicht
erwähnt wir schaffen damit mittel und
langfristig angelegte Lösungen die
unsere Gesellschaft durch diesen Winter
bringen und wir werden auch noch mehr
tun
die AFD nennt unterschiedliche Gründe
für die steigenden Preise die
Bundesregierung die etablierten Parteien
die ominöse grüne Inflation sie erwähnt
sogar den Krieg in der Ukraine aber sehr
erwähnen nicht mit einem einzigen Wort
wer für diesen Krieg verantwortlich ist
Putins Regime hat diesen schrecklichen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine begonnen
dort liegt die Verantwortung dafür dass
tausende Menschen gestorben sind
Familien auseinandergerissen wurden
unschuldige ihr zu Hause verloren haben
und Millionen Menschen sich derzeit
Sorgen machen um ihre Zukunft und ihre
Existenz
und es hat auch einen Grund warum sie
diese Ursachen nicht benennen weil sie
Freundschaften pflegen zu den
Kriegsverbrechern dieser Welt weil sie
ihre hässlichen narrative in unsere
Gesellschaft tragen wollen weil sie
hetzen und Spalten und das ist das
einzige was sie können
sie haben absolut kein Interesse an
klugen und konstruktiven Lösungen für
die Menschen in diesem Land sie nutzen
jegliche Krise für ihre ideologischen
menschenverachtenden Populismus und hier
parteipolitisches Kalkül
doch unsere Gesellschaft ist klüger und
unsere Gesellschaft ist stärker als ihr
Hass und ihre Hetze
viele Menschen haben Angst in den
kommenden Wochen und Monaten entscheiden
zu müssen ob sie den Kühlschrank füllen
das Auto betanken oder ihre Wohnung
heizen ich bin froh dass unsere
Ministerinnen und ministertag und nach
daran arbeiten dass die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger nicht dazwischen entscheiden
müssen wir lassen die Menschen mit ihren
Sorgen und ihren Nöten nicht allein und
das ist auch gut so
Natalie public war das für die
SPD-Fraktion letzte Rednerin zu diesem
Tagesordnungspunkt die beiden Anträge
der afd-fraktion hier da ging es ja
einmal darum dass die afd-fraktion einen
Antrag vorgelegt hat der einen
Maßnahmenpaket gegen die Inflation
beinhaltet diverse Punkte sind da ja
angesprochen worden und der zweite
Antrag da der AFD da fordert die
Fraktion in der Energiekrise einen
Schutzschirm für Menschen mit
Behinderung und soziale Einrichtungen
auch dazu hat man sich ja hier
ausführlich ausgetauscht die beiden
Anträge werden jetzt in die Ausschüsse
überwiesen zur weiteren Berat